from so far away the son often seems a  perfect sphere of luminance but up close  it is dynamic and imperfect this is a  close-up of a sunspot a depression on  the son's face that is slightly cooler  and less luminance than the rest of the  Sun the sun's complex magnetic field  creates this colder region by inhibiting  hot material from entering the spot  sunspots are often many times larger  than the earth and typically last for  only a few days as the magnetic field  that creates them is constantly changing  around the sunspot you can see that the  Sun's face is a bubbling sea of separate  cells of hot gas similar to a pot of  boiling water these cells are known as  granules a solar granule is about a  thousand kilometres across and lasts  about 10 minutes after that mini  granules end up exploding contributing  to solar flares of ejected material  which sometimes threatened to disrupt  life on Earth